revision okay we're going to do these
three problems
in particular ways and as i'm going
through them
um i'm just going to draw your attention
to parts of the way we solve these
questions i'm not even going to finish
them actually some of them
this one i'm not going to finish i just
want to show you how it's done
and i want you to think about what's the
common thread that binds all of these
questions and our approach to them
what's the commentary that draws them
together
okay now let's have a look at the first
one x squared plus 2x minus nine
uh yeah yeah yeah definitely it does not
factorize nicely so you have one of two
choices of ways to
solve it what are the two choices
number one quadratic formula number two
completing the square
okay now even though you don't usually
do it i'm gonna make it a completely
square question okay
how do we do it let's kick this nine
over the other side
and then here comes the completing the
square bit right i have to add something
to both sides
what do i add one in this case i add one
you look at this coefficient you halve
it and then you square it halve it gives
you one
square it gives you one so x squared
plus
two x plus one equals ten added to both
sides
the reason why we added one is because
it makes the left-hand side
a square that's why it's called
completing the square right
okay so you factorize it and then you
take the square root of both sides
don't forget that that means on the
right hand side you've got two solutions
then just to finish it off you toss that
one over the other side
great okay same thing that you would
have arrived at if you did the quadratic
formula
because the quadratic formula is just
that in formula form okay
all right this question now when you
look at it hmm
what kind of a question does it look
like
right this is well this equation's not a
quadratic
but we can twist and turn it to make it
look like one right
what would be a good substitution to
introduce
two to the power of x equals y
yeah okay we tend to by convention we
tend to use u
usually because y is somewhere else in
the equation but
it doesn't matter if you is equal to the
x
then u squared is two to the x
all squared right but by your index laws
you remember
that that two and that x they're
interchangeable okay so this is really
four to the x
okay yeah so this is u squared plus
u minus one equals zero and then you can
deal with it
however you like you can use this or you
can do the formula you get a solution at
the end but you understand how it works
right now we've learned just recently
a new method for solving equations like
this okay
so let's use our t results let's you
know
you've let t equal this and you've
recited what's
fine what's cosine your results should
look like this 2t
plus 1 minus t squared
okay so you multiply through
bring your one over so these are gonna
disappear bring your t squared over so
you're gonna get two t
minus two t squared okay
you can divide through and you can also
factorize while you're at it
so you're going to get these two values
and of course that's
tan of x12 and then you go ahead and you
solve that okay you get three solutions
not two pi and pi on two from memory
okay but that's
something you guys right now so what's
the common thread
three different quite different kinds of
questions
what's um what binds them together apart
from that
that they're quadratics that's actually
a coincidence multiple solutions
uh okay number one yeah there are there
are multiple solutions to every
different question
uh there's algebra okay now more than
algebra
um and this is actually sort of getting
what i want to draw your attention to
each time we've kind of used an
algebraic trick
right we've done something like this
rearranging
which very conveniently uses a square or
here this substitution
right or bringing in this totally
separate thing
right which allows us to rephrase the
question so here this is not a perfect
square
right so you do what you need to to make
it a perfect square
and this is not a quadratic but you do
what you need to to make it a quadratic
and then you know how to solve that
and this well uh it's not you know
it's not they don't fit together nicely
so you do what you need to
to make them fit together nicely then
you solve it okay
so when you first learn these three
methods right the whole idea is we're
trying to rephrase
a question in terms you already know how
to solve
that make sense trying to rephrase
things especially this one's the most
obvious example
now